Have you ever thought that by being here,
you bring risk and danger for other participants in public?
You don't have to answer that question if you want.
Don't want to? Why not?
If you want to. If you want to answer.
I think we're all here for one reason and one reason only,
and the EBU is taking all safety precautions, uh,
to make this a safe and. And united place for everyone. And, um.
So I think it's safe for everyone.
How do you feel about qualifying?
I feel amazing. I'm so grateful for everyone who supported me.
And then how does it feel
that Netherlands and youth asked you to actually answer the question?
You did, she did,
I did.
Are you ever uncomfortable with everything that's going on?
I think, you know,
I feel. I feel great,
and I feel like I'm at the right place at the right time,
and I'm doing my job.
And. And even if you want the war to end,
this is another Christian one.
So there you go. Israel and the Netherlands have fallen out.
The Netherlands have actually said they're worried about safety.
Israel say they feel safe.
The politics of Eurovision continues here in Malma